[Music]
well my name is uh andreas
sabatini and i'm the ceo and founder of
rurio and it's a
is a farm where aims to produce top
quality olive oil in tuscany
today i'm going to walk you through how
marco restores his beautiful 583 years
old
fresco
[Music]
the first work that we have to do is to
consolidate the walls
the first thing is then really to take
the stones
that are unstable take them off
consolidate
whatever is underneath and then put
the stones back to their places
in this large fresco there are cracks
here and there
so the next step is to consolidate these
cracks
the cracks gets consolidated with
resin special resin
the next step is now to remove the
plasters that have been
painted over the fresco in the last few
centuries
and to do that marco the restorer needs
to get
archaeological scalpel and remove every
single bit and pieces
out of this huge surface
and it's a very delicate work because
if you are not precise enough of course
you can damage the fresco itself
now that the cluster has been removed we
can
apply japanese paper soaked with
water and ammonium carbonate this is a
very
delicate process and the reason why we
are doing is because
thanks to the japanese paper all the
dirt
and all the external components get
away from the fresco and there is a
process that can last up to six months
after all this work as you can see the
fresco is revealing itself
some of the colors are now vivid what
was underneath the plaster fortunately
is
still there for most of it we are
actually applying again a japanese paper
soaked with a different product
carbonite hydroxide
and this is a very important part of the
fresco restoration
because it stabilize the fresco itself
now that all these processes are
completed marco can start
the second phase of the restoration as
you can see there's a lot of gaps
in the fresco because some of the paints
has faded
some others were lost he's going to use
a very tiny
small brush and he's going to use
natural pigment like they were used back
in the 1400s
there has been the surveillance of the
italian
authority over this fresco we are not
allowed in italy to
paint back anything it is not present
the whole restoration took a long time
it took
18 months we are very proud that we
didn't lose
this piece of art in tuscany
you